zero that's our friend yes to a
mathematician this is a number but it
wasn't always obvious maths existed to
do Financial transactions to sell sheep
to buy copper things whatever and you
would use coins and there would be
values to the coin so you would say this
costs five pounds 20 Shillings or
whatever you don't do any trading with
the number zero I've got no sheep here
oh I'm gonna buy no sheep I'll give you
no pounds it doesn't make any sense
so there was no need for shopkeepers to
invent the number zero
they had the idea of five cows but the
idea of five not so much the idea of
fiveness they didn't quite understand so
a number like zero which is the absence
of well whatever cows whatever it was
made no sense to them I'm going to ask
Grady a question and see if I can catch
him out uh Brady it's zero an even
number
I think the answer is no but it feels
like it is because it's round
so this is an interesting okay let me
ask you another question is 16 an even
number yes yes so people have studied
this
people have a delayed reaction people
are not sure whether zero is an even
number now I can tell you that zero
categorically is an even number it will
follow every definition of an even
number so there was a an Indian called
brahmagupta who invented the idea of
nothing not being nothing but existing
as an abstract quantity in the
mathematics well then it goes to North
Africa and there's a guy called Al
quasimi and he writes a book about the
art of Hindu mathematics or Reckoning by
Hindu mathematics and that spreads
through North Africa to Spain and so
forth and it becomes they think Arabic
numbers so you have all the numbers plus
zero
that was fine until 1200 when Leonardo
of Pisa also known as Fibonacci
translates this book it's a wonderful
idea but this is in the period of the
Crusades so people think these are
Arabic numbers not Hindu numbers because
it's come from North Africa
so the Catholic Church
objects to this because there are
Crusades going on and this is the work
of the enemy so in Florence for example
they banned the use of this Arabic
number zero and it was thought to be the
work of the devil because my definition
of an even number is something that can
be divided by two so greatest to tell me
the an even number is a number that can
be divided by two well zero can be
divided by two zero divided by two is
zero in fact in that sense it is the
most even number uh in ancient times
they have this idea of things being
singly even or doubly even so 12 would
be doubly even because you can divide by
two and then two again well by that
sense zero can be divided by two and two
and two and two it is the most even
number the correct definition of an even
number is it is a multiple of two
something times two something times two
well it is there's no problem with that
it's zero times two great uh Brady said
it had to be divisible by two well that
works uh zero divided by two
there's zero okay so it fits between two
odd numbers that might be a definition
for even let's do that there's zero and
over here that's one over here that's
minus one and then you get two over here
minus two
perfectly fits there are some rules for
numbers some arithmetic rules uh two
even numbers if you add two even numbers
together you get an even number well
that works uh zero plus four is four an
even number again that's what we want
we're saying zero is even it follows
every definition in fact if it wasn't
even then it would break our rules of
arithmetic which would be a disaster
it is true to say that zero is neither
positive or negative it sits here
between the positive numbers and the
negative numbers so it is neither
positive or negative the discovery of
zero was the most important advance in
mathematics of all because it made
mathematics capable of being understood
by everybody everybody could do this
mathematics the Babylonians the Greeks
they had the idea of a space so there
was a difference between 26 2 and 6 and
206 206 they had a space there they
didn't use the symbol zero but they had
a space it was like a more like a
punctuation mark so the Babylonians
would understand the difference between
26 and
206 but instead of using the the symbol
for zero they would just have a space
however if they wanted to write 260
was written like this and to us that
looks like 26. to them and in context
that would make sense but they didn't
have this idea of Zero by itself in the
9th century the first instance or the
first recorded instance of zero was
found it was actually found by a
gardener keeping track of the number of
flowers that his garden would produce
and he used the number 50 as we would
recognize it five zero after that point
they started to experiment with zero
what could it do there if you add zero
it makes no difference if you times by
zero you get zero
dividing by zero that caused them some
problems as it still does today in this
sense the mathematical sense the number
zero does not mean nothing it means a
quantity which you can manipulate in the
mathematics and so it's better to call
it zero rather than nothing
nothing is When you're counting there's
nothing there zero is the abstract
mathematical quantity
I'm cgp gray and my favorite number is
zero I like zero because it's it's not
an obvious number right you can have
counting systems where there's one thing
two things three things four things but
mathematics existed for a long time
without having a zero as part of it so
it's it's a number but it also isn't
anything in and of itself